Реліз однієї з найочікуваніших відеоігор у світі відкладається.
Глобальний дефіцит мікросхем загостриться.
Війна завдала удару по всій українській економіці.
Зокрема, й по ІТ-індустрії, яка останнім часом процвітала.
Війна може вплинути й на світових ІТ-гігантів: Microsoft, Apple і Amazon.
Адже робота цих компаній залежить від послуг 300 тисяч українських айтішників.
Уже незабаром увесь світ зможе відчути наслідки на собі.
Тоді як деякі українські розробники вже розпочали свою боротьбу проти Росії.
Усе змінилося. Мені треба змінювати формат роботи, усі цілі і плани.
Андрій Лук'янов - графічний дизайнер і експерт з маркетингу.
Коли почалася війна, він залишився без роботи в Одесі й виїхав з міста.
Зараз він з батьком живе в орендованій квартирі в Ізмаїлі, неподалік кордону з Румунією.
Його мати, сестра, дружина й крихітна донька виїхали в Румунію.
Життя тільки почало налагоджуватися.
Ми купили нову квартиру.
Ми з дружиною три чи чотири роки крім роботи нічого не бачили.
І нарешті все вдалося. Тепер нічого немає.
Моїй доньці незабаром чотири місяці виповниться.
Зараз я можу її бачити лише по відеозв'язку.
Андрій - один з багатьох українських айтішників, які нині шукають оплачувану роботу.
Його компанія змінила профіль - тепер це неприбуткова організація.
Вона розробляє програмне забезпечення для української армії,
яке аналізуватиме дані з соцмереж та інших джерел і допоможе розпізнавати російських військових.
Ми аналізуємо відкриті дані. Також у нас є інструмент, який аналізує фотографії.
Ми працюємо над тим, аби наші військові могли використовувати його на блокпостах
і впізнавати росіян, які, наприклад, є в їхніх військових реєстрах.
Андрій допомагає компанії шукати інвесторів, від зарплати відмовився.
Нині шукає можливості для віддаленої оплачуваної роботи графічним дизайнером.
Попри пандемію, українська ІТ-галузь процвітала.
Експорт ІТ-послуг зріс на 36% за рік: з 5 мільярдів доларів у 2020 році до 6,8 мільярдів доларів у 2021.
Кількість ІТ-фахівців збільшилася з 244 до 285 тисяч працівників.
Торік в Україні відкрили офіси міжнародні корпорації Apple, Amazon, Lyft, BlaBlaCar та Solarisbank.
Нас більше не сприймають як "дешеву країну".
Ми стали країною з кваліфікованими кадрами, які можуть виконувати складні задачі:
штучний інтелект, блокчейн, "інтернет речей".
До війни в Україні один за одним з'являлися яскраві стартапи.
Наприклад, Reface - додаток, у якому можна "помінятися обличчям" зі знаменитістю.
Або Grammarly - програма на основі штучного інтелекту, яка перевіряє правопис.
Або Ajax - компанія, яка розробляє системи безпеки.
Відголоски війни чи не найбільше на собі відчуває ігрова індустрія.
Весь світ чекав на вихід у квітні шутера S.T.A.L.K.E.R. 2, який розробили в Києві. Однак реліз відклали.
Розробники гри - студія GSC Game World повідомила: "Розробка відійшла на задній план.
Але ми обов'язково продовжимо. Після перемоги".
Тим не менш українська ІТ-галузь намагається не зупиняти роботу.
Нині у нас гаряча фаза бойових дій. Але по факту війна триває уже вісім років.
На мою думку, наші компанії здатні працювати навіть у нестабільних умовах і виконувати поставлені задачі.
Крім того, війна може погіршити й без того серйозну глобальну кризу мікросхем,
спричинену пандемією COVID-19.
В Одесі й Маріуполі знаходилися два великих виробники неону -
цей газ необхідний для виробництва мікросхем.
Україна до війни постачала половину всього неону на світовому ринку.
Тепер українські підприємства зупинилися, через що світові виробники мікрочипів зіткнуться з дефіцитом.
Звісно, жоден з цих наслідків війни не можна порівнювати з тим, що нині переживають люди в Україні.
Лише уявіть… Ми збиралися відправляти людей на Марс, натомість маємо російські танки в Україні!
Це просто… Неможливо осягнути. Це божевілля якесь!
Андрій зараз у безпеці. Але у будь-який момент його можуть забрати в армію.
Поки він продовжує шукати інвесторів для своєї компанії, яка розробляє систему розпізнавання облич.
Компанії потрібні потужні сервери для обробки даних.
Кожен має займатися тим, що вміє і може робити ефективно.
Зараз я можу бути корисним, бо роблю те, на чому знаюся. У мене є досвід.
Думаю, це найкраще, що я можу робити зараз.
Деякі великі компанії вирішили перемістити своїх співробітників у Польщу і Грузію.
Але сподіваються повернутися, коли закінчиться війна й Україна відновить свою цілісність.
Тим часом війна ведеться не лише на українській землі, а й у цифровій сфері.
Понад 250 тисяч добровольців відгукнулися на заклик міністра цифрової трансформації України
Михайла Федорова долучитися до так званої ІТ-армії.
Мета - кібератаки на Росію.
Членами цієї армії стали такі собі "патріоти-хактивісти".
Атаки, які вони здійснюють, можуть нашкодити, як, приміром, відключення урядових сайтів.
Але я б не розцінювала це як оголошення кібервійни.
Я б сказала, що це відбувається більше від безпорадності.
Коли відбувається кібератака, це впливає на доступ до води, продовольства, енергії, медичного обслуговування.
І це те, з чим ми стикаємося в плані ескалації ризиків.
Хакери атакували Україну ще до початку повномасштабної війни.
Урядові та банківські сайти були паралізовані. Шкідливі програми знищували дані на заражених комп'ютерах.
2014 року відбулася велика кібератака під час президентських виборів в Україні.
У 2015 та 2016 роках хакери паралізували частину електромережі - посеред зими.
У 2017 році саботажна програма знищила низку важливих жорстких дисків та серверів.
Те, що ми бачили з атакою NotPetya у 2017 році, було досить масштабним кіберзламом.
Атака вплинула на багато компаній у всьому світі, включно з міжнародною судноплавною компанію Maersk.
Багато галузей постраждали, загалом у світі було завдано втрат на суму близько 10 мільярдів доларів.
Тож це була досить великомасштабна атака з глобальними наслідками.
Кібератаки тривають і досі. Шпигунство, перехоплення даних, цифрові атаки на інфраструктуру, наприклад, електростанції.
Комнікація між військовими - це також ціль хакерів.
Можна собі уявити, що сьогодні, по суті, кожен танк, кожен літальний апарат - це теж комп'ютер, підключений до мережі.
Тож, навіть у цих пристроях вже масово використовуються кібертехнології.
У соцмережах теж ведеться війна.
Міністр цифрової трансформації України Михайло Федоров використовує "Твіттер" для антивоєнної кампанії.
Він попросив допомоги у Ілона Маска.
І той одразу відправив українцям комплекти для прийому супутникового інтернету Starlink.
Міністр цифрових технологій пан Федоров досить активний у "Твіттері".
Він чинить тиск на директорів великих компаній, щоб вони бойкотували російський бізнес.
Хоча шкода та страждання завдані обстрілами страшніші, збитки від комп'ютерних вірусів теж значні.
Віртуальна війна ведеться нині паралельно до реальної.